why
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp and welcome
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we are going to be discussing
the uk show super size versus
super skinny but first let's talk about
my sponsor build bar so i think i said
this last week but i got sent these bars
in december and
and i had them totally ruled out in my
mind as something i would absolutely
hate
but i tried one and i immediately texted
my agent right away being like
these things are so good so today's
snacky snack little flavor
is gonna be this one
banana bread i've been dying to try this
one so let's give it a little quick
taste test
tastes like banana bread wrapped in
chocolate
that was good honestly i would not care
if these were straight up chocolate bars
i would probably still be here talking
about them because
they taste so good they taste like the
love child between a marshmallow and
a nougat bar also you know i have to
laugh at the
zero guilt label on the package which i
think is
a super hilarious marketing claim
because remember folks
unless you stole it all foods are
zero guilt put that on your pantry door
and remember it but anyways
nutrition wise each bar has 17 grams of
protein so
i like them for adding to like a snack
or a meal to bump up the satiety factor
and since they are lower in sugar if i
were to have this as a post-workout
snack
i would always pair it with some fruit
or like a piece of toast
to balance the protein with the carbs
and natural sugars
to me the most important thing about a
snack is that it's satiating
and satisfying and this definitely
checks those boxes for me so if you want
to try them you can check out the link
in the description for 20
off of your order also you can check out
my disclaimer here on screen so feel
free to pause the video to read it
or check it out in the description below
with a big trigger warning
like the biggest one for this video
this may be disturbing to my followers
with distorted eating tendencies so
please feel free to skip this video
if this does not support your journey
and also don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on a video
all right folks snack time's over
because i'm probably going to make
somebody
crazy with my chewing so let's get down
to business
now if you haven't heard of this
dumpster fire
of a show supersize versus super skinny
it was a british television program that
aired for seven years
between 2008 and 2014.
and if you ask me it was seven years too
many
now to give you a brief summary of the
show the show pairs up
one larger bodied individual aka the
super-sized
with one smaller bodied individual aka
the super skinny so yeah
we are off to a pretty inhumane
start considering that the entire show
hinges on pathologizing people
based on their body size cool
anyways these two poor souls meet at a
feeding clinic run by dr christian
jensen where they're weighed and
insensitively
shamed let's take a look come and meet
each other hello
daryl weighs 33 stone yeah daryl this is
yasmin
she weighs seven and a half stone this
means that we could fit
four of her into you what
the actual [ __ ] if this isn't evidence
of
insensitive fat phobia in the healthcare
community
i don't know what is i think i'm gonna
need like a a drink
to watch this show anyway
after this friendly little introduction
the participants move into the feeding
clinic for five days
where they're forced to swap diets the
intro of season one
explicitly says dr christian jessen
will be stuffing the super skinny and
starving the super sized
how the did the show even get
approved i think we better just die
straight into my five reasons as to why
the show should have
never aired on tv because i have to
drive home after this and i'm going to
try not to get
too riled up reason number one the sole
goal of the show is to manipulate weight
or bmi not improve health
now in each episode dr jensen's goal for
the two individuals
is to either lose or gain weight for the
big dramatic
final weigh-in ugh of course it is
i am really so over this common weight
loss transformation show trope
incorrectly suggesting that physical
body changes
are the most important indicators of a
diet's success when we know that
metabolic health
can improve even without budging the
scale
but of course seeing improvements in
your blood pressure or a1c
doesn't drive ratings like dropping
those dramatic lbs
unfortunately dr jensen isn't the only
professional
on the show that i feel like reporting
to their regulatory board
in the first season holistic
nutritionist gillian mckeefe
parades around the uk on a mission to
reduce the size
of the nation's rears holding a sign
that says
ban big bums honestly
i can't make this up
and fear some fat fighter jillian mckee
crusades against the nation's big bums
why
why if that wasn't bizarre enough
she then has a group of women try out a
bunch of bum
tightening gadgets and creams measuring
their bums before and after the
month-long trial to see
how many inches they lost these
experiments
are just so bizarre i need to know where
their research teams even
found some of this stuff they have them
shocking their behinds with
electricity cycling in a vacuum pod that
sucks your body
and smudging clay all over themselves to
remove
toxins from their ass this
makes goop look like the cdc anyway
i am not really sure why a holistic
nutritionist is promoting the use of
expensive random gadgets and creams that
have
really no scientific backing to spot
reduce the size of women's behinds
not only does this seem totally out of
scope for a woman
of her education and training but i do
not understand the focus
on bums in the first place research
suggests that gluteal femoral fat aka
that pear
shape actually may have a protective
role by reducing bad
ldl cholesterol raising good cholesterol
improving insulin sensitivity and blood
sugar levels
so yeah generally speaking the fat
in your ass is not a major health
concern
also i know that this is all for
dramatics and sensationalism
cells on tv but my goodness
this woman's counseling skills are
appalling
running around poking women's bums
telling them that they feel squishy
is that something that you would want
your nutritionist doing in session
i think not and while i get that some
people respond to a tough love approach
research suggests that body shaming only
makes people sicker
and heavier in the long term moving on
reason number two this show is truly the
worst is that it relies on fat phobic
shock and shame tactics
to encourage people to lose weight there
are so
many examples of this i can't even keep
track including some of the points i
already made about the show
but in later seasons they fly the larger
bodied individuals
from the uk to the u.s to meet some
morbidly obese individuals for what they
call a
terrifying glimpse into their future
let's take a look at the super-sized
man's response
do you think the memory the picture of
jeff
in his bed like that really unable to do
much at all let's face it you know do
you think that's going to stick with you
in in crying in distress of what's
happened to him i mean
it's enough to deter anyone this totally
shocked me good call that was the point
yep shock value is always the point
of good tv interestingly while the
premise of the show pits the
super size against the super skinny
participants
the latter never are subjected to the
same
body shaming fear factor experience even
though arguably
their health isn't equal and in some
cases even
greater danger now reason number three
that this show sucks
is that it's extremely triggering for
individuals struggling with disordered
eating and eating disorders
at both or all ends of the weight
spectrum
first the show erroneously suggests that
disordered eating is
only an issue in the super skinny
individual
when we know that this can and does
affect people across the weight spectrum
in fact
while i'm not going to attempt to
diagnose any of the participants on the
show
there's a good chance that their
super-sized participants
are also struggling with problematic
food tendencies
it's important to remember that weight
is not always a defining criterion
for an eating disorder but unfortunately
individuals who are
normal weight or are overweight may be
led to believe that because they're not
underweight
that they're not sick enough to have an
eating disorder
the result is that normal weight
individuals may be
really struggling but are barred from
seeking out professional support
needed for recovery now the show also
overlooks the fact that eating disorders
are
actual mental illnesses they're not just
the result of
a lack of nutrition education in fact
most people with eating disorders have a
tremendous
nutrition knowledge base i mean there's
a reason why disordered eating is
statistically
rampant amongst nutrition students and
interns but force feeding a chronic
undereater huge portions of food for a
few days
in effort to immediately stimulate an
appreciation of eating
is both ill-informed and arguably
quite dangerous now i also took a look
at reddit
quite bravely i might add to see what
kinds of things people were saying
about the show online honestly it's
exactly what i expected
but worse and trigger warning like huge
trigger warning here folks i heavily
suggest skipping this section if you are
susceptible to
disordered eating tendencies so the
first forum submission reads
anyone else feel super guilty using my
600 pound life
or super size versus super skinny as
fatsbo
i binge watch these shows when i want to
eat and somehow it helps me
i'm basically viewing these people as
everything i don't want to be
whenever i'm starving i watch amberlynn
read compilations and it helps me
restrict
and now when i'm just restricting i
can't help watching supersize versus
super skinny
and wanting to be the skinny one when
their eating habits are just
as bad another reply reads i
unconsciously
want to be like the underweight person
even though i know
that's really bad and another saying
doesn't matter if he's 10 centimeters
taller or heavier
at least my waist and ribs are smaller
again skip ahead if you want this
is triggering for me too now another
problematic form i found titled reverse
thinspo
reads when i see the super sized diets
i'll be like
i will never eat that much and i don't
want to turn out like them
then i restrict on the other hand i'll
compare the super skinny's diets to mine
and feel like i'm not trying hard enough
and i end up wanting to restrict even
more
it's horrible and the ed will never let
us win
and finally another reddit post reads
watching super size versus super skinny
and writing down all the foods to super
skinny eats in a full day
to create my new meal plan
yeah so this pro anna rhetoric inspired
directly from the show
and its themes continues for pages and
pages
on end i am literally just scratching
the surface here
but these threads paint a clear and
problematic picture
of how this show directly inspires
people who are struggling with
disordered eating to restrict their
intake at a disgust
and fear for how the super-sized
individual is portrayed
while comparing their own intake with
and aspiring to be as restrictive
as the super skinny by focusing on this
unhealthy dichotomy and avoiding the
opportunity to teach
real balance this show teaches
vulnerable viewers
absolutely nothing about healthy eating
in fact
it actively only offers displays of
unhealthy eating
as a how-to horror show about treating
one eating disorder for another and this
brings me to reason number four
why the show should have never aired the
show
does not promote realistic behavioral
changes
when the participants are in the feeding
clinic they're not given a realistic
individualized diet for healthy weight
loss or healthy weight gain
they're told to eat a diet so extremely
different
than what their body and palate is
accustomed to
there is no way in hell anyone could
reasonably expect it to be sustained
then at the end of their stay in the
feeding clinic dr jensen provides
participants with a meal plan in an
ominous red folder suggesting that they
follow it strictly
over the next 12 weeks to gain or lose
weight
in time for the final weigh-in
shockingly
the show never really explores the plan
in detail as education for viewers at
home
so for all i know it could be the same
over-the-top
unrealistic bull they're being fed or
starved of
in the clinic all the doctor seems to
emphasize is the importance of
changing their weight before they come
back obviously in real life any credible
healthcare provider
would make sure a client be sent home
with proper education
on reading labels balancing food groups
or macronutrients
and realistic portions of different
kinds of foods
but alas this social experiment is so
far from real life it is amazing they
got real humans to sign up
i also found jillian mckeith's nutrition
education contributions
super bizarre and also really
ill-informed
while she never actually interacts with
the two participants in the feeding
clinic
and maybe that's for the better she
instead is featured in a section of the
show
serving random people in public about
bum-slimming gimmicks
and then like in another episode of what
the jillian mcheath
three shirtless men hold three different
dishes while random people
in public settings guess which is
highest in calories
but what's strange to me about this is
that instead of them
making adjustments to those meals or
suggesting ways in which you could
easily make them more well-balanced or
satiating or increasing the amount of
veggies
she just recommends completely different
low-calorie meals
like talk about lazy and ineffective
nutrition counseling finally reason
number five that this show is
truly the worst is that its premise is
not only
not health promoting but it's actually
potentially
dangerous like really really dangerous
so dangerous i have no clue how this
show got
past ethics approvals let's remember
that the two participants are
forced to swap diets resulting in the
super skinny
taking in a dramatic increase in
calories
and the super size virtually starving
why is this so dangerous well when we
see a drastic
increase in calories overnight we worry
about something called
refeeding syndrome now refeeding
syndrome occurs
after a state of undernourishment when
calories are introduced too much and
too fast it's actually incredibly
dangerous due to sudden shifts in
electrolytes
with symptoms ranging from fatigue
weakness confusion inability to breathe
high blood pressure seizures heart
arrhythmias
heart failure coma and even death after
just
four days of refeeding and then on the
flip side
it can be really dangerous to
drastically cut calories for somebody
who is used to eating a lot more
severely reducing caloric intake can
result in nutrient deficiencies
extreme fatigue muscle loss and
metabolic declines
and so much more and that is not even
touching
on the likelihood of a binge now before
we end off i just want to mention that
the uk
actually released one season of super
size versus super skinny kids
so let's take a look if you dare
supersize versus super skinny is back
and this time with an urgent mission
[Music]
mums dads and carers by giving in to
your child's dietary demands you could
be putting your kids lives
in danger my
mama bear heart hurts just watching that
like as if parents don't have enough to
feel
guilty about now we're putting our kids
lives in danger by giving into their
dietary demands
yeah this deserves a whole other episode
to really fully unpack and explain my
stance on supporting kids who are
considered
too big or too small but i will just say
that if you think a show like super size
versus super skinny is dangerous
for us consenting adults you bet your
boots it's going
to royally [ __ ] up a lot of kids
also qualified pediatric dietitians will
agree with me
that it does not matter if a child is
large or small
they all deserve to have a trustworthy
relationship with their body
and that means not ever forcing food or
withholding food
your child will grow into the healthiest
happiest body for them if we
let them take the lead to thrive so
despite our best intentions as parents
manipulation almost always makes it
worse
if you want more information on how to
raise a healthy competent eater
definitely watch my video on the
division responsibility right here
i also strongly suggest the book helping
without harming by ellen satter
which i'm going to leave a link to below
in the description
bottom line i truly cannot believe that
this show was on the air for
seven years i mean while the show's
intentions may have
been to bring attention to the possible
health risks associated with extreme
body weights at either end of the
spectrum
it did not provide any scientific based
nutrition advice
that viewers can actually use in their
daily lives
to help them in improving their health
if anything as we saw from reddit forums
this show only worsened viewers
relationship with food
and their body and teaches viewers poor
unhealthy eating habits and i don't know
how many times i need to say this but
fat phobic comments and shame tactics
are never
going to be productive and help people
improve their health
long term so on that note this dietitian
absolutely believes that this show
should have
never aired and that is all for today
folks
thanks again to builtbar for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
other shows that you want to see me
review
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye